Are those just envelopes?
Let me see them.
, okay. It has the
It has all the
So, they get a certificate and
prize. Okay. You want to give both out
or you want me to do one?
Huh?
When
secretary
prizes from you. Okay.
You take this. I'll give the
certificates.
certificates. There we go.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
certificates and awards and prizes for
the Quran competition that we recently
had. Quran competition
was on the 26th of April, I believe it
was. And masha Allah, we have 52
certificates to give out, which is
actually a pretty big number.
So, masha Allah, alhamdulillah, that is
actually very great. We had good
participation
and our children worked nice and hard
for this. So,
I will announce the name
and then come up to get your
certificate. You get your certificate
from me and then you can get your prize
from
Ustadh Osama here. He was gracious
enough he was one of the judges with us
at Alhamdulilahi. And so they did a
[Arabic recitation]
we will start with
the first level, level one,
which was Surat Al-Bayyinah.
Surat Al-Bayyinah and actually Surat
Al-Bayyinah is not a very easy surah. A
lot of people have a tough time with it.
So, we have in first place Rahma
Hussein.
Rahma Hussein.
Surat Al-Bayyinah. Masha Allah.
Here is your certificate, darling, and
here is your prize.
Okay, second place is Salam Shafiq.
Salam Shafiq
or Shafeeq.
Salam Shafiq.
Is it this kid here?
[Arabic recitation]
Very good. Masha Allah.
Number three, Arzan Khan.
Arzan Khan.
Third place, Arzan Khan.
I guess put that on the side. I don't
think he's here.
Okay, fourth place
is Maryam Shafiq.
Maryam Shafiq.
Maryam Shafiq. Get your she's not here
either.
the
which we are on 2 3 Maryam Shafique.
Okay, next place is
Meraj Mostafa. Meraj Mostafa.
Meraj Mostafa. I'm getting a lot of
lot of duds here.
Where's all of our first level?
Okay.
Rinaz Fatima.
Rinaz Fatima. There she is.
Masha Allah.
Here you go, sweetheart.
Masha Allah. Very good.
Okay, next is Talia Abdul Aziz.
Talia Abdul Aziz.
Come on up, Talia Abdul Aziz. Masha
Allah.
Here you are. Here's your
prize.
Yusra Naji.
Masha Allah. There you go.
One for each hand. And
next is Ali Al Qatami.
[Arabic recitation]
When?
Oh, there he is.
Masha Allah.
Congratulations, Alush.
Here you go, buddy.
Okay, next is
Alma Shafique.
Masha Allah.
Congratulations, sweetheart. Good job.
Next is Amir Hijazi.
Amir Hijazi.
There he is.
There you go, bud.
Okay, next is Yusuf Abdul Karim.
[Arabic recitation]
Yusuf, you look great today, man. Masha
Allah.
Good job.
Next is
Al-Mu'tasim Labib.
There he is.
Walking tall.
Congratulations.
Next is Muhammad Labib.
Brothers.
Are you brothers or cousins?
You're brothers? Which Hey, I think I
gave you two. Hang on. Did I give you
two?
Oh, that's just me. Okay. Thank you.
Maybe you deserve two. Omar
Al-Assadi.
Omar Al-Assadi.
Masha Allah. Omar,
fantastic, fabulous.
Okay, next is Razan Raji.
Razan Raji.
Okay, next is Saif Shafiq.
Saif.
Where are you, bud?
Saif Shafiq.
Congrats, bud. Take your certificate.
You don't take it, I'll keep it.
Okay.
Okay, now moving on to level two. Again,
that was a grade for level one Surat
al-Bayyinah. Now, it's I I guess it's
getting
more difficult, right? Yes.
That was the lowest level, so we're
actually getting more difficult. Level
two was Surat at-Takwir.
You don't hear Surat at-Takwir in salah
very much, do you?
People are afraid of it, that's why.
Okay, so first place in Surat at-Takwir
was Ayan Mahin. Ayan Mahin.
Masha Allah, Ayan.
Good job, bud.
Next is Lean Hassan.
Lean.
Look at the darling.
Okay, next is Maria Abdul Razzaq or
Maria Abdul Razzaq.
Not here?
Put that to the side. That's one, right?
Okay, next is
Areej Raji.
Areej Raji. Areej Raji.
Areej is not here.
Okay, next is Misk
Abu Awad.
Misk Abu Awad.
There she is.
Misk Abu Awad. Good job, sweetheart.
Okay, next is Muhammad Ahmad Sultan.
We have
bil ism al-thulathi masha Allah Muhammad
Ahmad Sultan. Tayyib, Zain Dudu.
Zain.
Dudu. There you go, bud.
Take your
prize. Next is Iman Barmawi.
Iman Barmawi.
Good job.
Surat at-Takwir. All this
little thing did Surat at-Takwir. Next
is
Alma Dudu. Alma
Is she taking this for your
sister?
Good job, bud.
Okay, next.
Moving on to the third level.
Third level is Surat al-Muzzammil. Surat
al-Muzzammil.
Okay, and we have Surat al-Muzzammil.
First place is Dalia Sahtout.
[Arabic recitation]
Masha Allah.
Very good, darling.
Next is Sirine
al-Qatami.
Very good, Sirine.
Proud of you.
Okay, next is Maryam al-Faq.
There she is.
And all of her splendor and glory.
There you go, Maryam.
Okay.
Going back to Arzan Khan for Surat
al-Bayyinah.
Arzan Khan.
[Arabic recitation]
Salma Lucas.
Okay.
Next is
Zahura Mustafa.
Bint Sabr. Okay.
Okay. Next is Adam Abdul Razzaq.
Adam Abdul Razzaq.
Adam Abdul Razzaq. Okay. Next is Khalil
Campbell.
Khalil Campbell.
[Arabic recitation]
Congratulations. Good job.
Okay, moving on to level four, which is
Surat Al Mulk.
And we know that this surah is very
important.
This is one of the chapters that the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would recite every night, correct?
And Surat Al Mulk recited every
night, the reward for reciting Surat Al
Mulk every night is what?
Min adhab al qabr will protect a person
from the punishment of the grave. We all
need some of that. So, at the very top
of that list, Yusuf Campbell.
Yusuf Campbell.
He's right there.
Every time I see this boy, he's about 6
in taller than the last time I saw him.
You're nothing but arms and legs.
Masha Allah. Congratulations. Taib, next
is Maryam Campbell.
Maryam Campbell. Maryam Campbell. She's
here.
Is she here?
Okay, the Campbell tribe is taking over.
Okay, next is Omar Sahtout.
Omar Sahtout.
Is that how you say your last name,
Sahtout? Okay, congratulations. Very
good, Omar.
Very well-mannered young man. Next is
Deena Elkhayyat.
[Arabic recitation]
Masha Allah, Deena. Very good.
Okay, next is Muhammad Hijazi.
[Arabic recitation]
Next is
Aqib Hussain.
Aqib Hussain. I don't think they're
here.
Aqib Hussain, he's not here.
Okay, next is Majid Mostafa.
Majid Mostafa. Or is it Majeed?
Sometimes it's hard to tell.
Majeed Mostafa.
Okay.
All right, next is
Surat Al-Mujadila.
Surat Al-Mujadila. This is level number
five.
And we have one person with a 96 score,
excellent score.
Qamar Abu Awwad.
[Arabic recitation]
Masha Allah, Qamar mithl al-qamar.
That's a very high score, young lady.
Tayyib, moving on to
level number six.
It says five, but it's actually six.
And that is Surat
Shu hadha?
Surat
What is it? Tahar. Surat al-Tahar. Shu
Surat al-Tahar?
Surat al-Tahrim.
Okay, made me nervous. I thought there
was a surah of the Quran that I'm just
learning about. Surat al-Tahrim.
And this is also, I guess, level number
five. It's listed here as number five.
89%
Alisha Husnain.
[Arabic recitation]
on her shoulder,
ready to slay. Okay.
Very good habit, don't leave your purse
behind.
Tayyib, moving on to
level number six.
this is Surat al-Hadid. Surat
al-Hadid. Not an easy surah.
It's a very with a shabah with a 100%
[Arabic recitation]
That's an impressive score there, masha
Allah. Hamad Muhammad.
Next is Adam Namour.
Adam Namour.
He's got the guns out, right? The sun's
out. God has guns out.
Okay, number
three, also 99%
score, Husaiya Abu Awad.
Very high score.
[Arabic recitation]
99% score if I tried right now.
Masha Allah.
Next is Mariam Abdul Aziz.
With a 94% score. Honestly, they were
This must have been real hard to judge
because you've got 199 99 94. I mean,
this is impressive scoring there. Masha
Allah. Very good. Very hard work. Also
with 94 is Yaseen Muhammad.
[Arabic recitation]
And you are brothers with Yaseen, right?
Or brothers with Hamad.
So, Hamad beat you beat you out today,
huh?
Okay. I don't know if you're going to
just let that happen. You're just going
to walk and just
Okay. Next is Mahdiya Muhammad.
This is your sister, Mahdiya Muhammad.
Mahdiya Muhammad. Masha Allah.
So, we have three siblings fighting
tooth and nail.
All of them all three of them Hafiz.
Masha Allah.
This is your certificate. Masha Allah.
Very good.
So, three Hafiz out of this household.
It's incredible.
next place,
which is at 89 89 out of 100. I mean,
it was a very close
very close. Ali Lucas.
Ali Lucas.
Ali Lucas not here?
Okay. And then moving on to Surat
ar-Rahman.
Surat ar-Rahman, we have four winners
here
with a 100% perfect score.
Dawood Jan.
[Arabic recitation]
Okay, next is Lara Hassan.
Lara Hassan, this is the second sister
to win.
This is
Dr. Asim's daughter. Both two daughters
won here tonight.
And 95%
that is very impressive.
Next is with 89%
Aisha Labib.
Come on up, Aisha Labib.
Labib.
You can get it for your sister. Is she
being bashful?
Okay, next is with an 88% score, Hisham
Ahmed.
Hisham Ahmed.
[Arabic recitation]
The last one is not here? Yes.
Mashallah, tabarakallah, that was an
incredible feat, a great achievement for
our youth. We've got 52 of our children
have memorized
very lofty
very lofty chapters of the Quran. So,
this is actually incredible. This is no
small feat. And so, as a community, what
one of us does reflects on the whole.
One of us, what one of us does. One.
Even one of our children. Each of our
children represents the whole.
So, when one of us fails, we've all
failed, and when one of us achieves,
we've all achieved. So, mashallah, a big
thanks to the teachers, the judges,
jazakallahu khairan, and a big thanks to
the parents
for their hard work and their diligence
with their children. And inshallah,
until the next
Quran
competition, we'd also to thank
our
coordinators, our youth coordinators
that have graciously worked hard to put
this together, Zakariya and
Malik and the rest of the youth
coordinators, jazakallahu khairan.
on behalf of all of us, we thank you
very much for your hard work and your
diligence.
jazakallahu khairan.
[Silence]
Amen.
I got it.
I got 100.
Yeah, yeah. I was thinking of it.
I got it.
I got to get out.
No.
I don't know what I'm doing.
[Arabic recitation]